foreign
[Music]
Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy
and yet another side of the confusion of
our age Plano Texas city councilman Tom
Harrison was recently in hot water
because of Islam Plano mayor Harry
larizelaire wanted him to resign and
local Muslim groups said they would hold
protests until he did what was his crime
calling for a ban on Islam in public
schools in which no religion is supposed
to be taught as fact or favored the ACLU
and atheist groups fought for decades to
get Christianity out of American public
schools but did they rush to defend Tom
Harrison of course not
the controversy began when Harrison
shared a short video on his Facebook
page with the words share if you think
Trump should ban Islam in American
schools La Rosa Lair first gave Harrison
a chance to get back on the politically
correct reservation he said I waited to
hopefully see some type of retraction
that his account was hacked I'm not sure
why that was there but that didn't
happen and so he called for Harrison to
resign he said Mr Harrison's position
indicates that he is unfit to represent
this richly diverse City this conduct is
inconsistent with the values of the city
of Plano
Dallas Imam Omar Suleiman who last year
prevailed upon Google to alter its
search results to conceal criticism of
Islam was likewise enraged he said when
an entire group of people are targeted
either by a teacher or an elected
official then those people are unfit to
educate or to lead I think that's what
the post is really all about he vowed to
Drive Harrison from office he said we're
going to Stage protests we're going to
continue to mobilize to make sure that
the councilman is replaced
nafi's pathan of the Islamic Association
of Collin County Texas was on board with
that he said I hope the city councilman
understands the consequences and accepts
the demand from mayor Harry
in the face of this onslaught of
intimidation Harrison folded almost
completely issuing an embarrassingly
groveling apology here's what Harrison
said I want to sincerely apologize to
the Plano Muslim Community for the
unintentional hurt I caused by reposting
something on my personal Facebook page
that wrongfully implied I am anti-muslim
my intent on inputting this on my
personal Facebook page was to emphasize
that Christianity is not the only
religion being targeted for exclusion in
our Public School it was not meant as a
personal attack against the Islamic
faith as a Christian it is my belief
that all should be free to worship as
they choose but we live in a time where
any practice of religious expression in
public schools is rarely tolerated my
hope is that due to the rightful
negative response to my post that it
will spark A Renewed discussion about
all religions and their place in our
Public Schools my other regret is that
my personal action has reflected poorly
on the city Plano my action was personal
in nature but I should have remembered
this past Monday night's Council
discussion none of us are ever truly off
duty none of us are perfect and we will
all be judged One Day by the highest
Authority until then I ask for
forgiveness within the community and
acceptance of my sincere apology
this did not of course mollify any of
his critics but amid all of Harrison's
groveling he did make one valid point
about Christianity having been driven
out of the public schools while Islam is
now being introduced
should Islam be taught as fact in public
schools and given a privileged position
that is not accorded to other religions
this is actually happening even in Texas
where the Harrison imbroglio raged
Liberty High School in Frisco Texas
recently established a prayer room for
Muslim Students drawing a rebuke from
Texas Deputy Attorney General Andrew
Leone who said Liberty High School's
policy should be neutral toward religion
however it appears that students are
being treated different based on their
religious beliefs such a practice of
course is irreconcilable with our
nation's enduring commitment to
religious liberty
but in response Liberty High School
doubled down and kept its Islamic prayer
room
there have been reports of Islamic
indoctrination in public schools also in
Georgia Tennessee North Carolina New
Jersey and elsewhere
is it not possible to have a reasoned
discussion about this without charges of
being anti-muslim and islamophobic
given the response to Tom Harrison's
Facebook post apparently not watch for
him to be driven from office and
disgraced utterly for his islamophobia
and for the presence of Islam and
America's Public Schools only to grow
larger I'm Robert Spencer
foreign